councilman
and our president we certainly want to
welcome him to tarrant county we're
proud of the culture and the heritage
here we're americans we're texans and we
remain true to our values
so much of what we value is demonstrated
by the men and women in uniform
i especially want to thank the our
female service members today as we
celebrate
international women's day
i also
i also want to thank congressman
for his services
later this month just a few miles from
here we'll be breaking ground on the
national medal of honor museum in
arlington
we respect
and greatly appreciate all of our
veterans
and everything they've done to maintain
our freedoms and we're praying for those
who serve today
as we toured our va clinic and resource
connection
we saw how dedicated we are to making
sure our veterans get the health care
and the health they need
through the direct proper funding to our
counties and other related programs
tarrant county will continue to provide
veterans with much needed additional
support including housing and wraparound
services
while we can never fully repay our
courageous men and women for their
distinguished service
we must do everything we can to honor
their sacrifice
and help them to continue to lead
successful lives
we're doing our part here in tarrant
county
we look forward to working with others
who are doing the same
we must unite
in being sure that our national veterans
are being served
at this time i would like to welcome to
the
congressman mark beasley
judge whitley thank you very much good
afternoon buenos dias how's everybody
doing
good i'm mark bc congressman for the
33rd congressional district where
[Applause]
and fort worth has an amazing history
when it comes to veterans uh when you
think about jim reiter and his
flying cross distinction uh flying b-24
liberators when you think of the rosie
derivatives that work at the bomber
plane at conveyor
for so many years uh
helping us
in the theater in the pacific and in
europe
when you think about
the men and women of iem machinists that
work at the plant still today incredible
contributions uh when you think about
our local american indonesian post post
8 38
right here fort worth texas one of the
first black holes
helplessness we have veterans here
that are dealing with asian orange we
have veterans here
that are dealing with cancers that they
have picked up overseas we have veterans
here that are dealing with all kinds of
nowadays uh some greater than others uh
but at the end of the day we all need to
step up and help them and i'm so proud
that the president of the united states
joe biden has made time
to come to fort worth texas
so he could hear the stories of veterans
here in the metroplex
in dallas fort worth that have
sacrificed uh so much from our country
here's some of these stories about
what they're going through
and how we can be helpful
uh to them uh in the future in addition
to the president being here uh and my
colleagues
we also have the secretary of veterans
affairs us here mr mcdonald who uh loves
fort worth because he has a sibling that
lives here uh and
um and and and again just delighted that
they are here today because we know that
these
uh
that these issues that affect our
veterans uh that they're very serious uh
that uh that it also affects the
families
uh and uh and that we're trying to do as
much as we can
to help them uh and with that i would
now like to introduce the stage uh jay
kelsey who represents the sixth
congressional district just in my
southeast representative
thank you mark thanks to all of you
i usually
don't write any prepared remarks when
i'm talking to my brothers and sisters
and the reason for that is i generally
don't know how i'm going to feel when i
walk
but the feeling i always know i am going
to have that i'm going to have is that
of love
love for my country love for my state
love for my community
and when i look around this room
i see patriots americans texans brothers
and sisters and
perhaps more importantly those who love
them
there's a lot that's not right in our
country in our world today these are
difficult times these are scary times
but the one thing that always brings me
back
is that at the end of the day
we don't put an rd in front of veteran
they're just veterans and the ability we
have to work as americans as colleagues
up in congress
came because of the sacrifice that you
made
as ray blessed to serve 20 years the
united states navy is both a pilot
and as a jtac
i spent a lot of years defending my
country
but i did so on the shoulders of people
like you
those of you who've gone before
korea
vietnam some drafted some volunteer
you did your duty
and now that i'm an elected official in
congress it's my duty to take care of
you because the cost of war
isn't just guns bullets and lives during
the war
there's a price to be paid for every
conflict we're in
it comes for everybody
some other to some different time
and that bill always comes to
we need to be we need to keep that in
mind whenever we're preparing to go to
work how we conduct the war the
strategies you use and understanding
that at the end of that war we have an
obligation just like abraham lincoln
said
to care for him who shall abort the
battle and his widow
and his orphans
tonight i'd like to introduce
congressman colin already my colleague
on the va committee
and uh an outstanding football player
who loves his character
well good afternoon i'm happy to be in
north texas even if it's not
in my hometown dallas
districts of texas
as a member of the veterans affairs
committee i am so honored to welcome
president joe biden to north texas
some of the work that i am most proud of
in my work in congress has been on the
issues impacting our veterans
and their families and that work has
been consistently the shapeless thing by
far
i was thrilled when i learned that
veterans would be the focus of president
biden's unity agenda to discuss the
state of the union recently
we have to keep our promise to those who
serve and here in north texas we do have
a track record of getting things done
for our veterans by coming together
working together
in 2020 i led the effort and worked with
the north texas va baylor scott and
white to have a recently shuttered
hospital in garland donated to the va
the first project of its kind
services at the garland va now served
veterans across our region and i hope
that this can become a model for other
communities across the country
and last year the president signed my
legislation to build a new spinal cord
injury center at the north texas va and
authorized other critical projects at
facilities across the country
one veteran said that the dallas
facility would be a godsend for himself
and other veterans managing these
critical injuries
i know this work is personal for
president
it's why his unity agenda will build on
the progress we've made here in north
texas for our veterans
i not too long ago traveled to
afghanistan and kuwait to meet with our
troops and service members
abroad and saw firsthand
there's a lot more that we have to do
either the benefits that they've earned
including those have been exposed to
toxic chemicals and burn pits
the house has passed a bill to fix this
and the senate should pick it up pass it
and send it to the president's desk as
soon as possible
president biden knows personally how
important it is that we have our
veterans back and investing in our va
facilities not only right for our
veterans but it also creates good jobs
in our communities
i look forward to doing just that
working with y'all and keeping our
promise to our veterans with this
president who believes so much and
that's keeping our promises thank you so
much
so
uh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
secretary dennis mcdonald
[Applause]
hello everybody it's an honor to be here
with you all
and of course
with president biden
the president and i and our group
including our members of congress
uh mark
uh
jake
and colin
just visited some terrific va employees
here in fort worth who fight like hell
every day
to serve vets as well as our vets have
served us
during that visit i was again reminded
of the bravery our veterans
the excellence of va workers
and
how lucky we are to have president bride
leading us championing va employees
veterans
their families caregivers and survivors
so thank you for everything mr president
you know
whenever someone signs up to serve our
country in the military
we make them a simple promise
you take care of us
we'll take care of you
you fight for us
we'll fight for you
if you serve us we'll serve you when you
come home
vets depend on that promise
and on us
there's no place where keeping that
promise is more critical
than toxic exposures
while veterans spot for us overseas many
of them were breathing in toxic fumes in
particular
later some of those vests developed
conditions that followed them home
and impacted or took their lives long
after the final bullets of war were
fired
it's our job to provide those vets with
benefits and care for those conditions
but for far too long those vets haven't
gotten what they deserve
president biden has made it clear that
those days
we will keep our promise to those vets
and get them the benefits and care they
have earned
to that end we've already established
presumptive service connection for
sinusitis rhinitis
and asthma we've announced our intent to
propose a new rule
that would have presented a service
connection for nine rare respiratory
cancers
we're fundamentally changing
proving and expediting how these
presumptions are established moving
forward
this progress makes president biden the
first president to proactively address
particular exposure for the vets who
have found our wars for more than 30
years
and more importantly it means that
twelve thousand more than twelve
thousand five hundred vets are finally
getting the benefits of their own
there's many more to come
this is just
beginning
president leading the way we'll stop at
nothing to get these vets timely access
to the benefits and care they deserve
because they've waited far too long
you shouldn't wait
longer
now i'd like to hand it over to
councilwoman elizabeth beck
councilwoman
is an army vet
an iraq war combat pet
representative for fort worth's knight
and her constituent
who happens to be my brother
and his wife
attest
to what you already know which is that
councilwoman back is an incredible
leader
in public servant
[Applause]
[Music]
fort worth is home to some 42 000
veterans
and as a community we strive every day
to make sure we aren't honored to
sacrifice the favor
just last year
we broke ground on the tuskegee airman
texas state veterans home a hundred
thousand square foot facility
named after some of the finest heroes
our nation has never known
because
this state-of-the-art facility will home
120 elderly veterans and is conveniently
located right next door to the fort
worth va club
so that when they need care they have
access
and making care
easier for veterans
is crucial because mr president
one of the things that you may know
about us veterans
is that for better or worse we adapt and
we overcome
we've been taught to suck it up and walk
it off
for decades we've suffered in silence
with the wounds of our service
both seen and unseen
we fought overseas only to come home and
reach another battle
one to have our illnesses recognized
we've waited through paperwork
we've waited on hold just to be told
that the connection was too tenuous
or the time too far remote
in 2005 i served your 12 month
deployment in tajirao
nearly every day of those 12 months i
woke up coughing and blowing black
matter out of my nose
we knew something was off
but we sucked it up and we walked it off
and we chalked it up to dustin here
of course i would later learn that this
was a symptom of being exposed to toxic
smoke from the burn pit that smoldered
24 hours a day
that was 17 years ago
and it wasn't until this past november
that i finally started the process to
receive my va benefits
why did i wait so long
because the idea of going back into
battle for benefits seemed exhausting
because i did not connect my symptoms
with my service
because someone else
somewhere else
had it worse than i did
mr president on behalf of veterans
across the city and across this nation
i want to say that we don't want
anything we don't deserve
we aren't asking for something that we
shouldn't have
we are simply asking not to have to
fight again
thank you for fighting for us
thank you for ensuring that veterans
have the support they need to fully
address the consequences of work thank
you for taking the bold step to
recognize the effects of environmental
exposure associated with wartime and
thank you for removing the red tape to
access the care and benefits we've
earned
ladies and gentlemen
it is my privilege and my honor to
welcome to fort worth texas the 46th
president of the united states joe biden
[Music]
hello everyone please please for now
i don't know who's coming
i want to thank you councilwoman you
know look i said they're on the way out
the thing that
bothers me the most when
veterans aren't looked out for
is every single solitary veteran
deserves
a treatment dignity
you shouldn't have to ask for a damn
thing
it shouldn't be can you help me
because i've got a problem
we should say how can we help
and so uh
i uh i thank you for your service
i thank you for all of you who are here
for your service
and i hope uh i hope that
hearing uh
hearing you will uh inspire more
veterans to do exactly what you're doing
sign up
sign up for the benefits and support
you have earned
what i found
with my son what i found with my friends
i found the generation of vietnam
[Music]
you should be asking you should be
letting us know
you should let us know what is bothering
you what is the problem because we owe
it to you
it's great to be here toward worth of
the resource connection
and i'm able to spend time with
mary parker earlier very briefly i want
to thank you for the passport into town
and i also want to thank judge uh
and all of the city council
members city council and
county council members as well
i want to thank you
i often tell the story i got elected to
the county council in my state we have a
uh
we're like in mindedge illinois we have
one state with 60 of the population
so a councilman has a district seven
times as big as a house member
and three times big as a state senator
and uh i did not want to run but i ran
just to show the flag unfortunately i
won
and they reapportioned me it was in 1970
i got reapportioned from a four-year
term to a two-year term because my the
opposition party saw more in me than i
saw in me
and i was forced to know what we say in
public life up or out
and i ended up running for the senate
before i was old enough to be sworn in
didn't expect to win that either and
here i am you're stuck with me uh
but uh
but the reason i ran for united states
said it was too hard being a county
councilman
you'd knock on the door and say my name
is joe biden democratic candidate for
the county council and they look at you
like and you know what they're thinking
well you know part of what they're
thinking
what's the county council do
will you affect people's lives as much
as anybody else and uh people go county
council
anyway
but uh i just think that uh jake you're
a fighter pilot you get this stuff i
mean you know i mean you can smile jake
it's okay
jake's a republican i like the hell out
of he's got
no i'm serious this guy's the real deal
the three congressman you have here two
of them look like they could they really
could and did play ball and the other
one looks like he'd bomb you and uh
it's a it's a tough group but a good
group look
i want to thank you uh and your staffs
for welcoming us to town
it's a one-stop-shop connection for
people in this county to the services
and benefits they need and that's
important
and i'm here today to talk about the
critical community it serves
our veterans
their families caregivers and survivors
i'm joined today by the bipartisan group
of texas reps that are here and i care
deeply about these issues congressman
mark veazey is
i want to thank him so much for
giving me the passport into his district
here and i want to let them know how
proud i am to sign the law the bill to
create a national monument to medal of
honor winners and recipients and the
values they represented it was a very
important thing you did
and congressman colin mallory
i want to thank you for your work in the
veterans affairs committee and house of
representatives particularly
your leadership dealing with veterans
mental health issues and congressman jay
gilsey
a member of the house veterans committee
a veteran himself served 20 years united
states navy
multiple combat tours as well
congressman thank you all for being here
and for allowing me to be with you
and continuing to serve our country
you know
i've often said and i mean sincerely
from the bottom of my heart veterans are
the backbone the spine the sinew of who
we are in this country
one percent of you these days one
percent of you who serves all the rest
of us the 99 percent who aren't
with you deserve to treat you with the
dignity and respect and service that you
deserve
you're the best of us and we owe you
and i've always believed that and i've
said this from the time i was a young
senator
we have many obligations in the united
states senate united states congress
president united states to the american
people
to the elderly to the poor to those in
need but we only have one truly sacred
obligation i mean this sacred obligation
that is to train and equip those we send
into harm's way
and care for them and their families
when they come home
only a small percentage i said
deserve and claim the title of veteran
more than 1.4 million of them are living
here in texas that's about 6.5 of your
population
and to be a veteran is to have endured
to survival and survive challenges most
americans will never know
and you have done it and you've done it
for all of us all of us
week ago during my state of the union
message in washington i spoke about
the bipartisan unity agenda four big
things i think all of us democrats
republicans independents can agree on
and rally around one is dealing with the
opioid epidemic which is stealing the
lives of so many people
two mental health for our children that
are in the wake of all that's happened
because the covet and all the all the
consequences there's over a million
people out there who are no longer
sitting at the kitchen table this
morning because of covet
and people worry about that and the kids
particularly third is ending cancer as
we know it which i'm confident we can do
and fourth is supporting our veterans
fully supporting them
these traditions unite us because they
impact america in every single solitary
state
issues that go beyond partisan politics
because they're about people about
people our neighbors
caring for our veterans has been a
central focus of my administration since
day one
and for the last year the department of
veterans affairs led by secretary
mcdonough has been the linchpin the
linchpin of our government-wide push to
make life better for american veterans
providing assistance through this
pandemic like job training and housing
we're helping lower income veterans
access va care
debt free we're expanding access to
health care services for women veterans
the lgbtq community veterans
we're implementing a plan to bring down
the rate of suicide among
service members and veterans
you know it's sad to say
but to this day we average 17 veterans a
day commit suicide
every
single day
more than get killed in combat
every single day
it's an absolute tragedy
it demands not only a holy government
approach
but a whole of country working together
to deal with this issue
texas one of those states protesting
participating
in the governors of mayor's challenge to
take on this crisis
and as i announced my state of the union
message
we're focusing on meeting the specific
care and needs for all our veterans who
suffer because of their service for all
our veterans
we learned a horrible lesson after
vietnam
was harmed the harmful effects of agent
orange which were dropped upon so many
thousands of veterans
and the years
it took to manifest illnesses and
veterans because then the veteran had to
prove that whatever his problem was
directly a consequence of agent orange
well we passed the law that i was proud
to be a co-sponsor of a long time ago
saying that if you were
if you had
agent orange drop upon you
it was presumed that the illness you had
was the consequence of that
now we're even slower to connect the
dots to what's happening to those too
many vietnam veterans living in the
lurch unable to access the care they
needed
it was only in the past year that we
added bladder cancer and conditions of
on
under active thyroid and parkinson's the
list of conditions tied to ancient
orange exposure as science told us more
decades after the exposure took place
it took far too long to reach that
decision in my view and i refuse to
repeat the mistake when it comes to
veterans of our iraq and afghans afghan
wars
not only did they face the dangers of
the battlefield but they were breathing
toxic smoke and burn pits where they're
near where they're based i was in and
out of afghanistan and iraq
23 times
i spent a fair amount of time there as
the united states senator and his vice
president the burn pits that incinerate
wastes of war
medical and hazardous materials jet fuel
and so much more just dug in big pits
we're not far from the hooches not far
from where our veterans were sleeping
when our troops came home
the fittest among them the greatest
fighting force in the history of the
world too many of them were not the same
headaches dizziness numbness dizziness
cancer
and we know we don't know yet enough
about the connection between burn pits
and each of these diseases so many our
veterans are now facing but i'm
committed i'm committed that america
make the commitment to find out
everything we can
i'm committed to the families like
danielle robinson the widow of sergeant
first class heath robinson who joined my
wife jill in the vice pres in the
first lady's box of the state of the
union
sergeant robinson was born a soldier
national army national guard combat
medic and kosovo in iraq
stationed at the same bases and around
the same exact time as my son major beau
biden united states army
in baghdad sergeant robinson was
stationed yards from burn pits the size
of football fields
and back home in ohio
danielle and their little girl waited
for him to come home
to coach the soccer team to build legos
but when he finally came home
cancer likely caused prolonged exposure
to the burn pits ravaged his lungs in
his body
a soldier who could bench press 315
pounds squat 400 pounds run 2 miles on
12 minutes
would be bent over in the bathroom gaspy
for air
danielle working full-time turned to a
become a 24 7 caregiver
scared to leave him alone for even a
minute
he was just 39 years old when he was
held as she held his hand and he took
his last breath
but daniel said he
danielle said he never stopped fighting
and neither did she
she kept fighting for his memory in his
memory for our veterans and their
families are going through the same
thing today
families like hers like so many of yours
you're the reason why we're doing
everything we can
we've increased funding for va research
to study the health effects of toxic
exposure in the military
we're speeding up the process to
identify and address an adverse impacts
from military-related environmental
exposure
we're following the science in every
case but we're also not going to force
veterans to suffer in limbo for decades
if the science is even even if it's
evenly divided
when the evidence doesn't give a clear
answer one way or another the decision
we should favor is caring for our
veterans while we continue to learn more
not waiting not waiting
so i directed
i directed the va to move quickly to
review more of the cancers and provide
determinations of whether or not
they're presumed to be service connected
within 90 days and by the way
you saw what happened in the what
happened when at 9 11 when the buildings
went down in new york
you saw
the thousands of
firefighters
who in fact were because of the toxic
smoke they inhaled
finally finally because some of the
people on the media and in in
entertainment insisted that they'd be
compensated for
well when diseases are so rare that
there isn't enough evidence we'll
examine other factors as well
and this week secretary secretary
mcdonough is developing a new rule that
will add several rare respiratory
cancers of a list of presumptive
conditions for certain veterans
we also need to know more about which of
our veterans may have been exposed to
burn pits in the first place or other
environmental toxins during their
service
to record possible exposures before
service members separate from the
military
so we're building a more comprehensive
database from the department of defense
and veterans affairs to use to track
access to exposures
we're working hard to educate everyone
across the va system about the potential
impact of specialized care needed for
burn pit exposure
urging veterans to sign up for the va
burn pit registry and to make sure we
know about they know about the benefits
that may be available to them
you know what i found about veterans
as we worked for those were trying to
deal with the mental health problems
is you're used to always giving you
don't think you have a right to ask for
anything
you don't think you have a right to ask
we're asking you
asking you to tell us
tell us where you've been
tell us what your needs are
not to be ashamed of us to be proud of
we owe you
improving training for va providers to
make sure they're equipped to diagnose
and treat exposures to related
conditions and this year launching a new
where net network of special care
specialized care providers
and call centers to help connect
veterans with questions about exposure
to care that's consistent comprehensive
and high quality folks
these are the kinds of steps that can
make a difference
in getting the proper care for more
patients
and providing support for veterans
especially those facing cancer diagnosis
and every one of you know
the earlier cancer is diagnosed the
greater the prospect of dealing with it
the greater the plan
prospect of curing it
it reinforces the new goal of my cancer
moonshot
to cut cancer deaths
the death rate by 50
over the next 25 years at a minimum to
create more supportive experience for
all the patients and families
secretary mcdonough is part of my newly
formed cancer cabinet the department of
veterans affairs is an essential part of
our whole of government initiative
because we're going to invest
billions of dollars solving this problem
to turn cancers from death sentence into
treatable diseases
these are all the things my
administration is moving on we're not
waiting we're not waiting
but some of the most important next
steps need congressional action
both the united states house of
representatives and the senate have
bills in motion that would extend
eligibility period for va care for burn
pit related health impacts from five
years
to after leaving the military to a
minimum of 10 years
and what open enrollment all veterans
who served in iraq and afghanistan and
in february the senate passed their bill
to do just that unanimously democrat and
republican
and the house bill that passed this last
week would do even more
expanding health care mandating research
reforming the process of determining
presumptions
and adding more conditions to the list
of presumptive care
both of these bills have bipartisan
support
these are the bills to unite the
american people these are the bills that
will deliver necessary care for our
veterans and their families
i must get those bills to my desk so i
can sign them immediately immediately
[Applause]
we have a sacred obligation as a nation
i promise daniel robinson and i promise
all of you here today
that we'll do better we must
we owe you we owe you
i can't say enough about the veterans
community
and there's a famous expression by
a famous english poet who said
they also serve who only stand and wait
to every husband and wife of the
deployed
of the deployed husband or wife
to every child the mom or dad deployed
we owe you
we owe you
because they also serve only stand and
wait
i remember the
head of the national guard in the state
of delaware
wife
used to say a prayer my son got deployed
my wife is a schoolteacher
who got up earlier than i did to get to
school i'd get to the train at 7 30
train
and i walked downstairs i wouldn't be
i'd just be had just had shades and had
my trousers on to get a cup of coffee
she'd be standing over the sink like
many of you have done looking out the
window
mouthing a prayer
that she was given by the commander's
wife
a prayer
a prayer for her
son who was in harm's way
all of you did that
all of you do that
all of you worry about that call
so thank you
thank you as well
concluding point i'll make and we talked
about it
the congressman i on the way down
you know this is an incredible
generation
911 generation
that fought
they served in a way i think they maybe
they're right up there with the greatest
generation because they not only got
deployed once
but sometimes twice
three four times into harm's way
they come home and go back
and after knowing
that they cleaned off the blood of the
seat of that up armored humvee that they
were in where they lost somebody
and they have to saddle up and go back
out again
an enormous generation an incredible
generation
i was telling the guys on the way down i
remember flying into
iraq one of those times
and i went in the cup the cockpit
and there were i believe seven members
six members five men and one women
and one woman
i asked the question of all them i said
how many is this your first tour duty
nobody raised their hand
second tour duty nobody
third tour two of them
fourth tour two of them
fifth two or one
no other generation
has been deployed redeployed and
redeployed and redeployed
that takes nothing away
from the world war one and world war ii
and vietnam generations
but it's one thing
to serve and come home
and then go back
and go back and go back
so we owe you
we owe you all
every veteran in here
and every family member a veteran
may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops thank you
for all you do
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wait
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
first